I thought he was the man to lead us
through the long night but I was wrong
do you like games little man you would
spill in this holy place the gods
won't mine they spill more than the
rest of us combined
who are you no one a girl has been given a
second chance there will not be a third
it's all I think about what was taken
from me I know what happens
there's no hiding from this we have to
fight
stand at the head of our army where you
belong show them what Lannisters are
what we do to our enemies
the real war is between the living and
the dead and make no mistake the dead
are coming
Dragons do not do well in captivity
how do you know this that's what I do I
drink and I know things
hey youtubers is Charlie new Game of Thrones Trailer
so let's break it down
we drink and we know things it's what we
do if you didn't know they screen the
first episode at the premiere last night
I haven't seen any actual spoilers but I
will talk a little bit about what
happened and what people were talking
about
but yes careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened on the show
so far most of us in this trailer is
self-explanatory but we're also going to
do a little bit of speculation too so
here we go the opening narration over
the scene that we've actually seen a lot
of the scene of them trying to get to
Jon Snow's body is tormund Giantsbane I
thought he was the man to get us through
the long night I was wrong they're all
just trying to figure out what to do now
that everything's gone sideways or at
least it seems like it's gone sideways
we don't know how much of this footage
is from later in the season but I'm
guessing that most of this is from the
first couple of episodes we moved to
marine Tyrion learning to deal with the
local populace do you like games little
man it looks like the old masters are
going to try and retake marine now that
Daenerys has gone they feel like drogon
is gone but the dragons are still down
in the pit so I love the way Tyrion
doesn't so much come out and say it but
he says dragons don't do well in
captivity how do you know that I drink
and I know things it's what I do
so I don't think he's outright getting
Quentyn Martell storyline from the books
if you have read the books if you
haven't don't worry they're not doing
that character I feel like he's safe
here even though the trailer makes it
look like he gets roasted
drogon we see flying over vias Dothrak
so whatever is happening in marine it
seems like Tyrion and Daenerys as small
Council are going to be on their own
with maybe the help of this new red
woman as much as the term makes you
think of Melisandre and I know a lot of
people are like what about Lyanna stark
if they're doing terror joy maybe she's
the red woman lying in a red pool of
blood I also think the really big hat
tip to the red woman title is this red
woman Jaime going directly against the
high Sparrow just suggesting he's not
afraid to reenact his Kingslayer moment
in actually you may have noticed the
transitions between scenes
sounds like an army getting pumped up
for war that's kind of the idea with the
way they cut this trailer in the way
they plotted the episodes out each
season of Game of Thrones the episodes
thematically tend to flow from what the
narrative is so like when we start out
in episode 1 Sansa and reek are still on
the run they're still scrambling they
find their footing then Sansa starts to
build her war engine to take back all
that was taken from her so all over the
place not just in the noir
they're all ramping up for a big crazy
war it just in King's Landing this is
going to be a war of the faith I like
that they cut this brand scene of him
underneath the weirwood with the Aria
scene in Jack and saying who are you
like bran is slowly discovering who he
is is the green seer he's going to have
all kinds of crazy powers it is going to
look spectacular so from the looks of it
when we see him here this is what his
body looks like but his mind will be
traveling all over the place that's why
we see him standing out at broad
daylight next to this white Walker the
last time we saw him the three-eyed
Raven said you'll never walk again but
you will fly arya also continuing her
evolution I loved Faye marsay here just
playing the game of faces with herself
just slapping her this
Daenerys scene of her being stripped of
her clothing by the Dothraki might
remind you of her in season one like
she's almost being reduced back to the
point where she was at in season one
before she'd amassed this army before
she had her dragons but she still does
have her dragons so I'll be really
interested to see how she deals with
this the second time around amongst the
Dothraki Khal jhaqo is kind of like the
new Khal Drogo so she might be forced to
marry him here we really don't have
enough context but this was the same
thing that happened to Daenerys on her
original wedding night to Khal Drogo
more jaqen H'ghar voiceover about Arya
getting a second chance better make the
most of it
cut to Sansa Stark making the most of
her second chance amassing an army look
at what she's wearing she has this
awesome stark sigil on her clothing so
clearly she's landed on her feet with
stark loyalists we don't really see the
banners yet but that actually comes
later in the trailer when she talks
about what was taken for her they have
several flashbacks to some of the big
stark related WTF Ramsay the red wedding
I wonder if these scenes are actually in
the season or if they just put this in
here for the purposes of the trailer Dan
and Dave were always kind of thumbs down
when it came to flashbacks but they
relented when it came to the Cersei
flashback we have the bran flashbacks so
it is totally possible that we could
flashback to the red wedding we don't
have a lot of context for Littlefinger
here but I'm assuming he's going to
appear during Sansa storyline at the
look on his face makes it look like he's
awaiting judgment like someone's going
to pass sentence on him what a
coincidence that they then cut to a man
condemned by his disease the
greyscale poor Sir Jorah I know what's
going to happen he's definitely going to
die eventually but I think it's going to
be a situation where as he gets closer
to death he just gets more and more
heroic
he's still going to go like there's a
ticking clock on his life now we finally
see Loras and Margaery against still at
the mercy of the faith and a lot of
people were wondering where Loras was
now confirmed still in prison awaiting
judgment and then we get some more
context for what's going on with Sir
Davos that looks like he's going to play
a huge part in the battle against the
Bolton's the Battle of the north there's
a traditional stark banner flying behind
him so it looks like he is going to be a
leader of Sansa's army survey the
battlefield a bunch of flayed men looks
like they're getting ready to charge the
field cut to Tiernan Varys surveying
their battlefield with this new red
woman I love the juxtaposition of scenes
here where it's like everyone is going
to be fighting their battle in the
trailer slowly ramping up from people
amassing their armies then charging the
field sir C voiceover juxtaposed with
the euron greyjoy scene he's on the
bridge here I think this is going to be
a moment from the books where he slowly
takes control the iron board Cersei is
talking about Jaime taking control of
their army which is somewhat of a book
thing but it's like way back from book 4
so they're looping back around to grab
some Jaime stuff but they're still
changing a lot from the books as he
arrives here through the Lannister army
he's wearing Lannister armor he's not
wearing his King's Guard armor anymore
so maybe Cersei discharges him that just
remains to be seen
he's going to be doing things that are a
little bit closer to book for Jaime that
was why a lot of people were up in arms
when he went down to Dorne in season 5
they felt like he was going to be doing
his book for stuff so now they've loop
back around and I'll actually connect
this to a later Brienne scene we moved
to another Tower of joy flashback
now this isn't confirmed Arthur Dayne so
don't assume this is a sim which is a
Targaryen guard fighting someone in
northern armor now this could be Ned
Stark versus Arthur Dayne remains to be
seen but I'm guessing not so much
because this Targaryen looks like he
slays this northern person and that is
not the way that Ned Stark verse Arthur
Dayne went down in the books
Cersei looks like she's going to be
encouraging Tommen to become more of a
leader show them what Lannister's are
now remember the voice-over is
disconnected from the scenes in this
trailer so her voiceover is her speaking
to another character from a totally
different scene than from this Tommen
scene but the actor who plays Tommen did
say that he's excited to show people
that Tommen really does have a pair like
he's really going to try and step up this
season but this shadow actually looks
like Jaime slaying the Mad King so I'll
be really interested to see if they
flashback to that
on the approach is just someone walking
up to the high Sparrow so taking the
literal context it seems like someone's
going to try and assassinate the high
Sparrow but when you look at the shadow
that's getting stabbed up here the head
looks nothing like the head of the high
Sparrow so just prepare to freak out for
Mad King flashback when you look at the
stonework in the background here - this
really does look like the inside of the
red key it has really high ceilings it
doesn't look anything like this small
room underneath bail or set more
Ironborn with yara Greyjoy tyrell army
marching in behind Jamie to bail or set
looking like they're going to try and
take Margaery and Loras by force and we
get the Davos hat tip to the Knights
Kings army we see the night's king who
actually looks like he's been recast
it's the same character from hardhome
but it looks like a different actors in
the makeup these are the three White
Walkers or just normal white walkers
when Davos says the dead are coming look
at the banner behind him that is a house
Mormont sigil so it looks like he goes
to get help from that young lady Morman
remember that funny Stannis joke where
he was asking for men for his army and
he got this really funny reply from the
leader of House Mormon who was like a
ten year old girl who was basically
giving him the finger there's only one
true Lord of the North so we're going to
cross my fingers here and hope the Davos
is talking to a ten year old girl in the
scene and boom fire is lit so White
Walkers are just destroying stuff
they're walking through fire here really
hard to tell who they're attacking they
could be marching on the wall they could
be marching on somewhere else near the
wall they've almost taken everywhere
there is to take in the north with the
exception of the place that brain and
the three-eyed Raven are holed up
underneath that weirwood so really like
two big directions they could go they
could go for brain in the three-eyed
raven knowing that they're very powerful
or they could hit straight for the wall
Samwell and Gilly still on that ship on
their way to Old Town three-eyed Raven
after what looks like the conclusion of
the Tower of joy flashback like you see
all these bodies in the background
more Arya training montage more Sansa
freaking out so this is like pitch bat
like people are now charging the field
so towards the middle of the season is
probably when it goes real crazy
really hoping that Sansa has Ramsay
flayed by the end of the season not
confirm you know Ramsay's one of those
people that they could choose to keep
around for a long time
Joffrey lasted a little bit longer than
three seasons so remains to be seen how
long Ramsay's going to be around but the
longer he's around and the more terrible
things that he does the bigger the
payoff when he finally does go down but
what sweet Justice would it be to have
him
laid just like the bolts inflate man
look at where Brienne and Podrick are
that is a totally banner so I'm
wondering if they make it to Riverrun
there are a lot of associated things
that are happening the Riverlands that
are really important will pricey
blackfish and really interesting thing
here Podrick looks like he is with this
Lannister army that Jaime was amassing
earlier in the trailer so if you're
really big fans of Brienne and Jaime it
looks like we're going to see them again
cannot wait to see if there's any
interaction with what's going on with
Sansa storyline because she seems like
she's going to be localized to the north
it seems like this Riverlands plot is
going to be independent of that one one
charging the gated castle black looks
like he's going to wreak some of the
Nights Watch Mira is back I love this
look on her face like she's still
under the weirwood and see something
crazy and they wipe the blood and we see
dragon fire what does that remind you of
the motto of House Targaryen is fire and
blood so thematically it works with that
and it kind of works with what's going
on in the season lots of blood is going
to be spilled lots of people are going
to go in so many spectacular ways it's
going to be so awesome so let me know in
the comments below what is your favorite
thing about this trailer just the idea
of the White Walkers marching the idea
that all these armies are going to be
going up against each other some of the
plot lines are straight out of the book
so we can talk about that when we get to
those episodes remember things slowly
ramp up then they get crazy probably
around the middle of the season so we
also have to talk about the stuff that
is not in this trailer obviously they're
avoiding Jon Snow there were a lot of
people at the premiere who have not read
the books that weren't we're talking
about resurrection or anything crazy
like that they're like well he's still
making it sound like they thought
because he was dead that he's not coming
back there's a lot of things that people
aren't say like you see a lot of
articles where people like well looks
like Jon Snow's gone I guess that's that
and it's hard to tell if they're writing
articles like that just to be clicky
just you know so people are like no he
can't be gone or if they really haven't
read the books and they don't know
anything about resurrection on Game of
Thrones but I'll just tell you guys you
can't resurrect a body that's still
alive he has to die before he can be
resurrected in Episode four is longer
than all the other episodes of Game of
Thrones this season so something special
is happening in episode 4 that could be
a number of different things but don't
be surprised when we pick up in the
first couple of episodes and Jon Snow
stays dead but remember we see Davos all
over the place in this trailer we do not
see Melisandre all over the place so
whatever
going to happen it looks like she's going
to be staying pretty close to John snows
body but more really good news new round
of the giveaway starts now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video it's just a $20
Amazon gift card because there's still a
couple things that are on break this
week I should have plenty of time to do
a Q&A so I'll just announced the winner
whenever I post that there was so much
stuff that happened yesterday just in
case you missed it you can click here
for my Suicide Squad trailer breakdown
and you can click here for all my Game
of Thrones trailer videos thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you